[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission on vous
conseille des livres vous savez pour le
thé ou pour d'autres saisons d'ailleurs
avec une invité et un livre que vous
allez adorer mon invité c'est Évelyne
Brest bonjour Patrice et le livre que
vous avez adoré s'appelle je veux
peindre et aimer le et est très
important on va on va le voir alors
Évelyne dresse je sais pas si besoin de
vous présenter mais enfin carrière
cinématographique assez incroyable avec
vous allez tourner avec Molinaro avec
audia avec deux villes avec Pierre
Baroux avec les torrescolas avec Patrick
soulman évidemment et la tendresse
bordel qui était un énorme succès et
puis vous avez tourné avec une certaine
Évelyne dress aussi
pour notamment pour pas d'amour sans
amour qui était qui était qui était une
adaptation d'un livre que vous aviez
d'abord
ayant vu le film m'a demandé d'écrire le
roman et puis et puis une œuvre
littéraire assez considérable alors on
peut citer les rendez-vous de Rango on
peut citer les tournesols de Jérusalem
la maison petit chez pas d'amour sans
amour donc qui est devenu ce livre et
puis un livre dont on avait parlé ici 5
jours dans la vie d'une femme et et je
veux peindre et aimer et je vais vous
laisser la parole comment je vais pas
parler tout seul mais
et alors il y a une troisième corde à
votre arc si je peux dire vous êtes
aussi peintre
alors je fais pas tout en même temps et
c'est
déjà que je ne dors pas beaucoup et
j'aime pas dormir je vais dormir mon
éternité donc ça je vais pas commencer
aujourd'hui et mais j'ai eu des périodes
différentes alors c'est pas
j'ai toujours peur qu'on dit bon elle
touche à tout
non c'est pas c'est pas du tout ça c'est
que quand je fais des choses je l'ai
fait à fond avec passion
pour moi il n'y a que le support qui
change je fais toujours la même chose de
la création
me raconter aussi beaucoup et je suis
mon matériau et puis voilà quand quand
j'étais en peinture je dis en peinture
comme on entre en religion
j'étais totalement immergé et on peut
pas dire que j'ai fait des tâches je
racontais des histoires aussi puisque ma
peinture est figurative et que j'ai été
exposée deux fois au Grand Palais donc
théoriquement
et justement
on va parler de votre votre héroïne qui
est donc peintre et c'est elle qui dit
je veux peindre et aimer
est-ce que vous auriez pu écrire ce
roman c'est justement vous devriez pas
été vous aussi peintre parce que
l'étoile dont vous parlez comme c'est un
personnage imaginaire même si parfois on
se dit mais non forcément existait non
c'est un personnage imaginaire c'est ça
d'accord totalement imaginaire sauf que
je
lui donne aussi ma psychologie
des roses noires des des hommes
nus des hommes noirs plutôt nains nus
bon évidemment c'est vous qui avez
imaginé c'est l'existence de ces
peintures
de créer une de mes toiles qui est
concupiscence sous les filles du
calvaire qui est une très grande toile
un diptique de 3 mètres sur deux et qui
raconte des religieux
dans un jardin et en prière sur le
cornet de glace à deux boules c'est un
peu subversif
la solitude parce qu'en fait tout ce qui
traverse mon travail et la solitude une
solitude
aimée par imposée
la solitude et c'est d'ailleurs la
grande question du livre c'est et moi
j'ai l'impression quand j'ai connu des
gens qui sont qui ont des des
bout de vie avec des artistes et souvent
ils disaient oui mais un artiste ce qui
passe en premier chez lui c'est là le
reste vient en deuxième
est-ce que est-ce que c'est votre
sentiment aussi c'est la question que je
pose dans le livre je veux peindre et
mais est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
faire les deux
la question que je pose c'est est-il
possible
d'aimer de créer et de rester libre
voilà moi non je vous réponds ce que ça
me paraît difficile
je ne citerai pas de
de peintre ou mais ne serait-ce que des
comédiennes qui étaient au top de leur
carrière et qui ont suivi un homme parce
que tout à coup l'amour et qui ont
disparu de la circulation et qui ne sont
pas revenus parce qu'il est très
difficile de revenir
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai que la création quand on
arrive à mettre sur le papier
trouver le mot juste la phrase juste ou
bien quand on peint arriver à créer
exactement ce qu'on a dans sa tête c'est
vrai que ça décuple le désir ça c'est
comme ça un procédure
que je ne m'explique pas mais en tout
cas qui existe et que je ressens moi
aussi voilà c'est vrai quand on est un
homme et qu'on a une femme à la maison
c'est facile
de satisfaire son désir et
d'autres choisissent la solitude et s'en
pleine pas du tout et
après on va aborder l'histoire du livre
mais justement cette question voilà il y
a l'art et la vie enfin et est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est spécifique aux
artistes c'est ce que par exemple je
sais pas des PDG des des pouvoirs
politiques
l'impression que ça passe quand même
avant les vies personnelles
le
pouvoir
donne du désir des couples bah oui
pardon
la preuve des hommes politiques
deviennent beaux tout d'un coup et
désirable non mais je vous assure c'est
un processus que que les artistes
connaissent aussi
ils prennent le pouvoir d'une certaine
manière sur leur œuvre et
alors on va venir au livre qui donc
l'histoire de Rebecca
sur
pourquoi avoir écrit
peindre je veux peindre et c'est pour
faire écho à Henri Miller qui avait
écrit
peindre c'est aimer à nouveau c'est à
dire que lui c'était avait raconté sa
peinture à travers ce roman et je
m'étais toujours reprochée de n'avoir
pas décidé de raconter ce qui m'était
arrivé lorsque je m'étais mise à peindre
voilà et donc l'impression de renaître
de revivre de d'être une nouvelle femme
enfin d'avoir accouché de moi oui
j'ai toujours
je me suis toujours vécu comme une moche
parce que j'avais une qui me persuadait
que je j'étais très moche et
lorsque
la première fois je me suis fait
beaucoup d'autoportraits et la première
fois où j'ai pas ma bouche et
je me suis aperçue qu'elle était pas si
mal que ça et que vous peignez pour vous
rendre compte que pour votre mère et
j'ai éclaté en sanglot voilà
c'est beau comme l'histoire et donc et
en même temps à l'époque
[Musique]
j'avais été
j'avais fait l'expérience d'être
animatrice
j'ai une émission qui s'appelait entrer
sans frapper tous les soirs de minuit à
une heure du matin sur Europe 1 et
Montaine de à l'époque et où
l'expérience avait été assez difficile
et donc je m'étais retirée du monde et
c'est là où j'ai découvert que j'étais
capable de peindre et
découvrez que j'étais capable de faire
exister quelque chose sur une toile
blanche mais ça ça m'a rendu invincible
vous écrivez d'ailleurs il n'y a rien de
plus intimidant qu'une toile vierge et
je lui disais mais il a la page blanche
c'est la même c'est la même mais oui
c'est la même chose et puis tout à coup
quelque chose existe et c'est vraiment
oui un accouchement de soi-même
extraordinaire et ça me plaît infiniment
alors votre héroïne
ça se passe entre les années en gros
1914 et 2 ans 30 enfin
pourquoi avoir choisi cette époque
alors je ne sais pas c'est venu comme ça
parce que vous auriez pu vous dites
forcément qu'elle a un peu de vous cette
héroïde mais vous aurez pu la situer
dans une contemporaine c'est vrai que
c'est une période aussi
absolument incroyable c'est à dire
beaucoup de choses se passent dans la
peinture beaucoup de choses se passent
dans la on parlera de New York tout à
l'heure où elle où elle arrive assez
quand Gershwin crée sa rhapsodie et Blue
enfin c'est vrai que c'est un moment
d'effervescence créatrice absolument
incroyable et de et de d'un monde en
même temps qui est en train de changer
puisqu'il va y avoir la guerre de 14 et
elle est importante dans votre livre et
au fond c'est beaucoup d'historiens
disent le 20e siècle né après la guerre
de 14
je
j'aime bien écrire des lettres
il y en avait beaucoup dans les les
soldes de Jérusalem
et
pour la petite histoire je suis
l'écrivain public de ma famille et quand
ma grand-mère hongroise voulait écrire
des lettres à me demander de les écrire
donc j'ai toujours entendu dire que je
savais écrire les lettres et
donc j'ai commencé par cette relation
avec le premier amour de mon héroïne qui
a à l'époque 20 ans et qui ne connaît
rien de l'amour et qui va
faire l'amour avec son fiancé l'homme de
sa vie à la veille du départ de ce
garçon pour la guerre de 14-18
à l'époque on partait faire la guerre la
fleur au fusil on allait défendre sa
France
il y a deux sortes d'amour chez cette
héroïne il y a il y a
au départ c'est un amour un peu maritale
enfin de couple hein qu'elle a avec
George enfin l'amour très pur très très
bon d'ailleurs
qui n'existe qu'à travers les lettres à
part qui à partir ils ont fait l'amour
avec son départ après c'est un amour
fantasmé puisqu'il n'est pas là mais on
apprend beaucoup de choses qui sont pas
là mais le deuxième amour on en parle
après c'est plutôt la passion enfin si
on pouvait catégoriser mais prenons
alors partons de donc elle vit dans la
région de Nîmes
et vous savez que je suis un écrivain
voyageur et je préfère tourner autour de
mon nombril dans des pays exotiques ou
bien ailleurs qu'à Paris et là j'ai
choisi Nîmes pour commencer pour
commencer et donc elle a cette cette
cette ce premier amour avec avec George
qui va mourir en 1917 c'est ça
à la guerre évidemment c'est un
traumatisme épouvantable je me suis mise
en la peau de d'une jeune fille de
l'époque qui n'a rien connu qui va
découvrir l'amour à travers les lettres
qu'elle va échanger parce que
bizarrement pendant la guerre de 14 les
lettres arrivaient absolument oui c'est
incroyable parce que de conditions
absolument dingues et les lettres
pourtant arrivaient c'est assez drôle
donc
on s'écrire chaque jour et ils vont
vivre intensément leur histoire comme
s'ils étaient proches l'un de l'autre et
elle va apprendre de son corps
ses émotions
ce qu'elle ressent sa sexualité et donc
tout va c'est comme ça et puis tout va
s'arrêter et elle va perdre en même
temps ses parents et elle va donc
hériter de la d'une grande maison à
Nîmes alors qu'elle faisait ses études à
la ruche
à Paris et
vivre dans cette grande étude notariale
du père une grande maison bourgeoise
trois étages et elle a pas besoin de
tout ça elle va donc se réfugier dans le
grenier pour pleurer vivre sa peine et
la peinture va quand même la sauver la
sauver bien sûr mais au fur et à mesure
qu'elle va se réparer elle va descendre
dans la maison jusqu'à se retrouver au
rez-de-chaussée et ouvrir les fenêtres
de sa maison et se donner à voir en
train de peindre et bien sûr et elle va
recevoir comme ça des visites des gens
qui vont venir la regarder peindre et
elle aura justement
une maman qui vient avec son fils
trisomique voilà Charles et qu'elle va
peindre et
très belle scène elle va beaucoup
apporter à cet enfant puisque elle va
le passage de la mer dit
elle voulait un enfant et elle dit pour
moi c'est plus bel enfant du monde bien
sûr et
pour mon héroïne Rebecca
c'est aussi une matière extraordinaire
cet enfant qui est différent parce
qu'elle peint la différence
donc Georges après elle va rencontrer un
autre homme alors c'est là un peu
l'amour passion avec Maxime
alors il est dans le cinéma
alors jusque là alors on est au moment
du cinéma
je sais pas si vous avez vu Babylone le
film de Damien Chazel j'étais très
surprise parce qu'il parle de la même
période que moi
de se basculement du muet au parlant et
donc maxime n'a encore fait que des
courts métrages c'est un jeune homme
aussi assez beau ou fringants
heureusement le rencontre d'une certaine
manière pour se sortir
et
mais lui il a des ambitions il veut
faire un long métrage et il a l'idée de
proposer son scénario de long-métrage à
une star de l'époque qui s'appelait
Gloria Swan Swan et
au fond de l'amour dans dans sa vie mais
vous savez vous voyez que lui il a
choisi entre son art et son amour
et vous dites oui quand il parle au fond
la vie de Rebecca ressemble à un désert
quoi ben oui bien sûr surtout c'est le
deuxième amour elle est encore jeune
elle est elle attend tout
de l'amour elle a pas encore décidé de
choisir sa peinture elle a besoin de la
peinture elle elle ne peut pas vivre
sans peindre mais en même temps elle
veut aimer
alors
il y a dans ces peintures il y a c'est à
dire mais évidemment Nîmes il y a des
arènes et dans les arènes il y a des
corridas et elle va faire des
impressionner par un taureau justement
qui est un qui a existé
comme beaucoup de
grands taureaux il y a beaucoup de gitos
elle va elle va
peindre la corrida et puis vous avez des
pages très belles aussi sur sur la
corrida
vous dites
modeler cette question en quoi l'animal
est différent de l'homme
la chanson Cabrel vous savez qu'elle
contre qui dit est-ce que les hommes
sont sérieux c'est ça quand et c'est
vrai que oui c'est une question qu'on se
pose qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il a oui
oui la différence
oui où est la différence et surtout
ils prennent des risques tous les alors
bien sûr quand on est contre la corrida
on pense que
tu es mettre des bondés bon
voilà
donc je
vais mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
beaucoup d'artistes ont tous le premier
c'était drôle c'était Picasso c'était
David
moi aussi Picasso aime la corrida moi
aussi Picasso et communiste moi non plus
de grands grands artistes ont été
impressionnés parce que ça il
considérait aussi la corrida comme un
art c'est un art c'est un combat
il y a deux
personnalités en face l'une de l'autre
et qui s'affrontent et c'est vrai que
c'est un spectacle magnifique
et
les couleurs et les couleurs de la
corrida sont très belles alors elle va
être remarquée et puis elle va partir
pour New York et alors elle part avec le
France
tous les gens
prenait le France premier du nom c'est
le premier Français
le premier oui c'est ça
le le menu du dîner
pâté de veau et jambon en croûte que de
langoustines sauce gribiche boire
d'amour à la cubaine et vinaigrette
ensuite les potages velouté de légumes
ici on mangeait tout ça
mais
de barres de l'océan et duvet etc ou
après les entrées alors c'est de la côte
de veau l'entrée après il y a les
légumes
les beignets les petits pois après des
pâtes spaghetti après la grillade la
côte d'agneau après les routines la
poularde de Bresse après les salades
c'est incroyable c'est le seul ça dure
10h quoi
mais en tout cas c'est c'est un vrai
menu hein
c'est pas possible
est-ce que
parce que c'est une question qui se
posent parce que quand on peint c'est le
corps qui agit est-ce qu'on peint comme
on fait l'amour c'est à dire est-ce que
c'est justement
la sensualité qui précède
l'intellectualité
comme je vous ai dit ça exacerbe le
désir de peindre de réussir à faire
quelque chose qu'on a dans sa tête ça je
sais pas quel est le processus mais en
tout cas oui ça donne du désir ce que je
voulais vous dire
c'est que entre
l'émission
l'animation à la télé et la peinture
j'ai eu une période trapèze ah oui vous
avez du cirque
et donc et j'ai fait du ballon le ballon
quand vous êtes sur votre trapèze et que
vous vous vous jetez
et bien il faut être dans le rythme et
si vous n'êtes pas dans le ré vous
tombez or quand vous peignez c'est
exactement vous parliez dans mon corps
oui dans mon corps j'ai ressenti
exactement la même chose c'est à dire
que quand je mets une couleur elle a
besoin de se retrouver comme ça dans le
rythme il y a une réponse un rythme mais
je pense que c'est un rythme qui est
oui dans le qui est presque il y a
l'instinct il y a le corps qui parle
enfin c'est pas c'est peut-être que
quand on décrit c'est plus intellectuel
mais quand même l'actualiser mais aussi
et mon corps travaille autant je me
donne de la même manière et voilà
peut-être si le mot qu'il fallait dire
je me donne et comme en amour et alors
on parle pour New York et là elle va
être exposé c'est le pierre Mathis qui
ouvre sa première galerie le fils
alors ce qui a d'extraordinaire et ça je
savais je suis très croyante et donc je
remercie Dieu à chaque étape de ma vie
de me donner ce dont j'ai besoin et bon
effectivement je commençais en 14
l'écriture de ce roman et
j'ai fait j'ai avancé dans mon écriture
et voilà que j'arrive à New York et dans
mes recherches je m'aperçois que c'est
le jour où
Gershwin
c'est quand même une époque de création
absolument incroyable c'est dire que on
est entre deux guerres on veut oublier
aussi peut-être les les difficultés des
terrible de la première guerre inventer
un nouveau monde malheureusement il y
aura ça va mal se terminer voilà il y
aura Hitler il y aura la deuxième guerre
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a cette dans
cette période là il y a une créativité
artistique absolument incroyable et il y
a d'autres personnages pardon parce que
on est obligé d'aller un peu vite
malheureusement non
de la même façon je trouve karmatisme le
fils Henri Matisse qui ouvre sa première
galerie et le personnage dont vous
voulez parler
j'imagine c'est Khalil
l'auteur du Prophète le deuxième livre
le plus lu après la Bible et dont on ne
sait ok oui et que les Bannet et dont on
ne sait pas en France enfin moi je l'ai
découvert qu'il était aussi peintre
voilà
et aux États-Unis c'est un grand peintre
il est autant
apprécié
comme peintre que comme écrivain et donc
on n'a pas parlé de du galleriste qu'il
a découvertes
à Nîmes et voilà c'est un homme qui
vient la voir peindre comme ça elle a
ouvert ses fenêtres là et puis il vient
la voir il vient tout les jours quoi
il lui dit et c'est grâce à lui qui va
qu'elle va partir à New York voilà c'est
ça et donc il lui trouve
un atelier de peinture mitoyen de celui
de Khalil jurass voilà donc tout ce qui
est écrit sur Khalil Gibran est vrai il
a véritablement peint dans cet atelier
et il a même acheté le building et
plusieurs ateliers et mon héroïne
s'installe dans l'atelier mitoyen et ils
vont avoir bien sûr des soirées ensemble
des échanges nourris philosophiques et
c'est un roman de voyage
à la Turquie et puis avec des personnels
tous les personnages à tous les
personnes beaucoup de personnes sont des
personnages réels pierre Baptiste a
existé
[Musique]
vous avez fait beaucoup de recherches
énormément comme à chaque fois dans tous
mes romans je
j'adore ça
et dans dans les tournesols de Jérusalem
j'avais aussi des personnages existants
Marcel Proust
Sarah Bernhardt Émile Zola nous étions
dans l'affaire Dreyfus donc tous les
personnages avaient existé et donc
j'adore faire cet exercice
passionnant de mêler justement là-bas la
fiction la réalité avec comme vous dites
tout ce que vous dites tu rajoutes du
libram et exister vraie voilà et vous
l'avez vous avez enquêté quoi si je peux
dire même si vous connaissiez bien je
crois le le personnage
je veux pas vrai aimer alors
pour vous dire ce titre alors on peut y
arriver
je veux peindre et aimer j'aimerais y
arriver je vais peut-être y arriver pour
le moment je suis tranquille je n'ai
qu'à
c'est très intéressant parce que votre
héroïne Rebecca elle est beaucoup dans
l'attente au fond elle a elle lui c'est
malheur avec et et est-ce que vous êtes
vous aussi beaucoup dans l'attente je
suis dans l'attente du Messie alors
le Messie n'est pas fait pour arriver il
est fait pour être attendu alors c'est
ma thèse évidemment mais je pense que
c'est la bonne thèse et c'est ça qui
fait avancer c'est pas une attente je
reste assise sur mes fesses
et c'est attendre en fabricant en
faisant en avançant et oui je suis dans
l'attente
vous êtes en train de décrire vous
l'avez peut-être déjà écrit un nouveau
roman on en parlera quand il sera publié
en attendant il faut dire je veux
peindre et mes autres éditions glyphes
et c'est signé évidemment Évelyne dresse
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci
[Musique]